la situation qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est la suivante on imagine
une sphère parfaitement réfléchissante
que l'on regarde et ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de déterminer la
direction que l'on voit dans
l'environnement qui nous entoure
lorsqu'on regarde une certaine direction
donc un certain point sur cette sphère
donc ici j'ai mis un petit exemple
d'image de ce qu'on voit dans une sphère
parfaitement réfléchissante vous avez
certainement déjà vu ce genre d'effet
d'optique et si on va essayer de le
modéliser par les mathématiques
alors tout d'abord on va imaginer qu'on
se place à une certaine distance de la
sphère donc je vais représenter le
centre ici à une certaine distance qu'on
appellera D
et notre œil se situe ici on va regarder
la sphère
alors lorsqu'on regarde la sphère la
lumière que l'on voit nous parvient d'un
certain point sur cette sphère
donc par exemple ici elle parvient de ce
point-ci et cette lumière qui donc est
un rayon lumineux a été réfléchi par la
sphère et en réalité elle provient de
cette direction là par exemple
et donc le rayon incident a été réfléchi
par la sphère et arriver dans notre œil
ce qui va nous intéresser c'est de
déterminer en fonction de cet angle ici
la direction de ce rayon de départ
alors on va tout de suite écrire
quelques notations ici on va utiliser la
normale au point d'impact donc ça c'est
simplement le rayon de la sphère à
l'endroit où se situe l'impact du rayon
lumineux on va par convention définir
que le rayon de la sphère vaut 1 si le
rayon de la sphère ne vaut pas un mais
par exemple 2 m et bien simplement ça
équivaudrait à multiplier la distance d
par deux donc en fait d ici c'est une
grandeur qui est à dimensionnelle ça
veut dire que c'est simplement la
distance qui nous sépare du centre de la
sphère divisé par le rayon de la sphère
ici on va noter alpha l'angle selon
lequel on regarde la sphère
et puis ce qui nous intéresse c'est
l'angle bêta donc si je trace une autre
horizontale ici c'est l'angle bêta qui
se trouve ici entre le rayon incident et
l'horizontal alors ces angles ce sont
des angles orientés en particulier donc
là ils sont tous les deux positifs mais
si on regardait vers le bas alpha sera
négatif et donc bêta en conséquence
serait également négatif puisque le
rayon lumineux serait parfaitement
symétrique à la situation qui se trouve
au dessus il proviendrait du bas
à partir d'ici on peut prolonger la
normale de la sphère ici donc quand je
dis normal ça veut dire la direction qui
est perpendiculaire à la sphère donc ça
c'est la tangente de la sphère donc on
voit que c'est perpendiculaire à la
tangente au point d'impact et les lois
de la réflexion nous imposent que
l'angle qui sépare le rayon réfléchi de
cette normale doit être le même que
l'angle qui sépare le rayon incident de
la normale donc ces deux angles qui sont
égaux on va les noter thêta
à partir d'ici on a tous les ingrédients
qui vont nous permettre de résoudre le
problème ce qui nous intéresse en
particulier c'est de déterminer bêta en
fonction de Alpha
alors comment déterminer cet angle bêta
une première observation qu'on peut
faire c'est que l'angle béta ici qui est
entre l'horizontale et le rayon incident
c'est égal à peu près on voit que c'est
à peu près la même chose que deux fois
l'Angleterre
à ceci près qu'il faut retirer ce petit
angle ici pour obtenir bêta alors quelle
est la valeur de ce petit angle et bien
on voit qu'on a deux horizontales à
l'intérieur desquels passent une même
droite ici qui intersecte les deux
horizontales ici l'angle s'étalpha et
donc d'après de la géométrie niveau
collège cet angle vaut lui aussi alpha
donc on peut écrire une première
équation c'est que beta
est égal à 2 fois thêta
- l'angle alpha
et ceci c'est ce qui va nous permettre
de résoudre la valeur de bêta mais
encore faut-il connaître la valeur de
thêta donc ce qui va nous intéresser
dans la suite c'est de déterminer cet
angle d'État
lorsqu'on peut faire c'est voir qu'ici
on a un triangle ce triangle si qui a
deux côtés dont on connaît les longueurs
des et 1
on connaît également un angle de ce
triangle l'angle alpha
alors ici on voit qu'on pourrait
utiliser des propriétés des triangles on
connaît par exemple la loi des cosinus
qu'on appelle aussi le théorème
d'alkachi ou la loi des sinus la loi des
sinus elle est un peu moins connue mais
nous dit simplement que la longueur d'un
côté du triangle divisé par le sinus de
l'angle qui est opposé à ce côté c'est
une constante de du triangle et donc si
on prend un autre côté et qu'on divise
par le sinus de l'angle qui lui est
opposé on obtiendra la même valeur
et en particulier dans cette situation
c'est cette loi qui va être très utile
et nous permettre de résoudre le
problème donc prenons cet angle par
exemple alors cet angle pour l'instant
on ne connaît pas donc on va l'appeler
Delta par exemple
et ce qu'on peut écrire avec la loi des
sinus c'est que le côté opposé d
/ le sinus de l'angle donc Delta
doit être égal à l'autre côté donc ici 1
divisé par le sinus de son angle opposé
qui est alpha
alors alpha on le connaît dès on le
connaît mais Delta on ne le connaît pas
alors que vaut Delta et bien ici on va
s'appuyer sur un peu de géométrie on
voit qu'on a ici une droite la normale
et sur cette droite on peut décomposer
l'angle plat ici en delta plus têta on
voit que si on ajoute Delta et état on
obtient un angle plat de 180 degrés
puisque ici ce trait est une droite donc
on peut écrire que Delta plus têta est
égal à un angle plat de 180 degrés c'est
à dire est égal à pi
et donc que Delta est égal à pi - têtard
alors le sinus de Delta ça va être donc
le sinus 2 pi - Delta
et là par un peu de trigonométrie on
peut se convaincre que le sinus de PI -
Angle c'est la même chose que le sinus
de l'angle lui-même donc ça c'est le
sinus de téta alors pour le voir vous
pouvez tracer votre cercle
trigonométrique
et puis on voit ici que si je prends un
angle thêta son sinus c'est cette
ordonnée ici si je prends pi c'est ici
et puis moins têta je retranche tes tas
donc j'obtiens cet angle ici et bien ce
point à la même ordonnée que téta d'où
le fait que les sinus soit égaux
donc ça c'est très utile puisque ici on
comprend que le sinus de Delta c'est
simplement le sinus de téta
et comme ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
déterminer tes tas et bien on va pouvoir
résoudre ici l'équation pour déterminer
le sinus de téta et puis tout passer à
l'arc sinus c'est à dire la fonction
réciproque du sinus pour obtenir la
valeur de temps donc ici quand on résout
on peut inverser les deux côtés on
obtient sinus de téta sur D
est égal au sinus de Alpha on multiplie
par des des deux côtés on obtient sinus
de téta est égal à D x le sinus de Alpha
et on résout en passant à l'arc sinus
des deux côtés et on obtient que Teta
est égal à l'arc sinus de d x le sinus
de Alpha
alors ici il faut faire attention parce
que l'arc sinus c'est une fonction qui
ne nous donne pas nécessairement la
valeur que l'on cherche vous voyez ici
que on a deux points différents sur le
cercle trigonométrique et donc deux
angles qui sont différents mais qui ont
un même sinus et donc à partir de la
valeur du sinus on ne peut pas
déterminer s'il s'agit de l'un ou de
l'autre
mais ce qu'on sait ici c'est que notre
angle alpha il est limité on ne peut pas
dépasser un angle alpha de plus de PI
sur deux
puisqu'on ne va pas regarder derrière
nous du fait qu'on regarde la sphère qui
est devant nous et pareil l'angle alpha
est forcément plus grand que moi puis
sur deux
donc en particulier les points qui
auraient un même sinus qu'un autre point
ici et bien on n'y a pas accès donc le
sinus de Alpha détermine en réalité
parfaitement la valeur de Alpha
ceci nous permet d'écrire que l'État
vaut effectivement l'arc sinus de d x
signal fin
et en remplaçant ici dans cette équation
on obtient finalement que beta est égal
à deux fois l'arc sinus de d sin alpha
moins alpha ceci c'est l'équation finale
l'expression finale qui nous donne
l'angle du rayon incident par rapport à
l'angle de vue selon lequel on perçoit
le rayon réfléchi
alors on pourrait faire une dernière
petite approximation pour essayer de
simplifier un peu cette expression et en
particulier on pourrait imaginer qu'on
se situe très loin de la sphère donc d
est beaucoup plus grand que 1
dans cette situation si on a des qui est
très grand devant 1 et bien on voit que
cette chose ici à l'intérieur va être
très grande sauf si le sinus de Alpha
est très petit or l'arc sinus ici ne
prend des valeurs qu'entre moins 1 et 1
donc ceci doit être borné ça veut dire
que si D est très grand sinus de Alpha
doit forcément être très petite et si
sinus de Alpha est très petit on va leur
absolue et bien ça nous impose que Alpha
doit lui aussi être très petit par
exemple par rapport à pi donc en fait
c'est assez logique si on se place très
loin de la sphère l'angle à travers
lequel on voit la sphère et bien et très
petit à l'inverse si on se plaçait très
près de la sphère on pourrait regarder
avec un angle beaucoup plus obtus
donc dans cette situation alpha est très
petit et donc on peut négliger cette
soustraction ici de plus le sinus de
Alpha est très petit et en particulier
le sinus de Alpha est très proche de
Alpha lui-même cette approximation elle
est assez connue ça vient tout
simplement du fait que le graphe de la
fonction sinus lorsque l'on est proche
de zéro c'est à peu près la droite y = X
et donc ceci devient à peu près d alphas
et donc bêta dans la proximation on est
très loin de la sphère c'est à peu près
égale à deux fois l'arc sinus de d x
alpha
pour finir on peut essayer de tracer
cette fonction
alors l'arc sinus c'est une fonction qui
est
symétrique à la fonction sinus donc ici
on a la fonction sinus donc la fonction
arc sinus ce serait un graphe de cette
forme là sauf que comme c'est une
fonction il ne peut pas revenir sur ses
pas donc elle s'arrête ici et ici en -
pi sur deux et en plus pi sur deux
lorsque le sinus atteint son maximum et
son minimum et ici comme on a deux fois
l'arc sinus et bien on obtient une
fonction qui fait deux fois cette forme
là
et donc qui atteint son maximum en PI
et son minimum
en moins pi
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit ça nous dit
simplement que lorsqu'on regarde tout en
haut de la sphère et bien en regardant
de très loin on observe derrière la
sphère avec un angle plat d'à peu près
pi
et si on regarde tout en bas de la
sphère on obtient la même chose un angle
plat mais cette fois-ci dans l'autre
sens de moins pi
donc en fait c'est pour cette raison
qu'ici si vous regardez très proche du
haut de la sphère et bien vous voyez en
fait ce qui se trouve presque derrière
la sphère et de la même façon ici vous
voyez à peu près ce qui se trouve
derrière la sphère pour cette raison
c'est se faire réfléchissante sont
utilisés au cinéma puisque en prenant
une simple photo d'une telle sphère à
une distance suffisamment lointaine on
peut observer un panorama à 360° de tout
l'environnement et c'est très utile en
3D par exemple pour projeter la lumière
d'un environnement sur des modèles 3D